and now your most recent film spencer
i have to say is my favorite work of
yours to date
it's not an easy task to take on
the most iconic figure
that we probably know in history modern
history
but you led us into this character
and you gave us a glimpse into our soul
in the most tactful and heart-wrenching
way
there's an ease a natural rhythm to your
performance that almost makes us forget
that we're watching a dramatization
dramatization
and
yes i mean listen i was basically
screaming to the scene yes diana take
your boys to kfc you deserve this
and that's what you do so well you just
invite us into the characters that you
play
in the way you inhibited them and the
way
that it doesn't feel forced or intrusive
and i admire the hell out of you for
that
and while i can go on and on about your
insane acting
talent and how you deserve every ounce
of recognition that's
coming your way i'm immensely grateful
to know you as a friend
i know um
that you're
funny as [ __ ]
that you're one of the smartest people
i've ever met
you're unapologetically
who you are
[Music]
and
i hope you know how much that means not
just to me but to the rest of the world
so before i cry
i would like
to present you kristen stewart
with the santa barbara international
film festival
reviewer award
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
[Applause]
that was really nice
charlize
who was supposed to fly here
had to drive and still came she's been
working really hard and i just love you
so much for being here is very sweet
um
so to one of the most generous and kind
and unstoppable women i have ever met in
my life sometimes in a scary way mostly
a sexy way but let's move on thank you
you are in aspiration charlize i want to
be you when i grow up oops do wait
um
i will continue to try and take a page
out of your book because what leads you
really does seem to be
your heart
you'll be not
uh um thank you roger darling and thank
you to the santa barbara international
film festival
um
thank you for acknowledging me at this
time in my life
not to make this about me but um
i'm in such a good place to receive it
as filmmakers we hope and hope for
reciprocity on every level
we want as i said we expect
from every member of the cast and crew
from every audience member to give
[Music]
to give every part of themselves because
we are
and you can't do that alone um
it's a it's a really wild
stupid precarious investment
if it's not mutual
it's not doable and when it pays off man
and you see your feelings reflected or
your work received that is a beautiful
life and it's not lost on me
not one second of any day
um so
yeah
film is my portal to life i am lucky to
have a family that instilled in me a
love of every single step of this
process every single soul that must
align to make something
it feels like a miracle every time
so pablo lorraine
i wish he was here right now because
then you could just see
he is a dreamer
he made a movie
[Music]
he made a movie about the inner life and
dreams of a woman so so tenderly coveted
and yet so painfully unknowable
that can only be an act of compassion
and from a dude man that just feels good
[Applause]
believes in miracles they exist because
of dudes like that he's not here right
now but i thank him forever for this
uh thank you neon for pushing and
supporting and loving this movie as much
as as we do i really love you guys
thank you to my whole team who's been
with me forever i love you so much
ruthie stev thank you
um
and uh lastly thank you to everyone in
this room for
just being here and sharing this space
with me tonight it is a beautiful thing
thank you
[Applause]